sylvie la vie d'une grande vedette de la
chanson française doit être une vie bien
remplie
existe-t-il une petite place pour les
animaux une grande place parce que à
chaque retour d'abord celui ci là il est
il fait partie des voyages parce que je
l'emmène un peu partout dans la mesure
du possible et puis les pratiques
il est petit et puis il suit partout le
chat c'est un petit peu plus sauvage de
comme vous voyez sont ils s'entendent
bien tous les deux à chaque j'ai
recueilli dans mon jardin qui est venu
tout petit comme ça sa mère l'a la porte
est chez nous et puis petit à petit on
l'apprivoisé puis j'étais à la première
à pouvoir l'attraper alors maintenant ça
y est adopté alors il ya un chat le
chien fallait chien
rapide
aussi
mon premier animal c'était un lapin un
lapin blanc qui ressemble un peu à ce
niveau il faisait office de chiens de
poupées il était dans l'est dans les
poussettes
il était vraiment adorable ce lapin puis
j'ai deux bergers allemands
cali et ringo
oh
j'ai eu un petit yorkshire que j'ai
perdus dans des conditions très triste
il ya six mois qui était mon chien en
fait qui vous suivait partout et on
s'adoraient tous les deux on avait nos
habitudes faisait sept ans que je
l'avais et puis le tout dernier celui-ci
qui est un bébé de neuf mois qui a
sommeil qui veut rien entendre
il est en photo sur votre gauche est de
notre dernier disque est ce que vos fans
mes créations sujet ah oui oui j'ai
demande en mariage
il va être content il va voir plein de
fiancé mais j'ai rarement vu des chiens
comme ça en france et j'ai géré à portée
de new york une une petite chienne et
alors ils vont certainement se marier
l'année prochaine s'ils vont avoir des
bébés
et puis il adore son chat alors là
depuis que le chat est arrivé c'est
devenu ces deux du l'amour entre les
deux ils ont absolument à croquer on
dirait un dessin animé on peut rire
c'est ce qui est formidable a dit les
animaux c'est que d'abord on n'est
jamais seul parce qu'ils sont ils sont
toujours là ils sont toujours à vous
faire la fête à vous attendre
et alors le chat n'est pas un chat parce
que il a pris les manières du chien il
ya très sage comme ça l'arrangé
voilà cricri via le chat non c'est pas
pour toi c'est faux critique alors ils
lèchent le chien pendant des heures et
puis alors une grippe jamais il ya des
pattes de velours et puis il prend des
manières du chien qui mord par exemple
mais allez viens c'est vous ça a duré
combien de temps tout ça combien de
temps ça va durer
mais ceci dit bon je vais faire le mort
quelques acteurs intime bon alors là il
est infernal eide qui n'obéit pas aux
quines obéissance mais il est très guèye
est très affectueux il est très joueur
oh
il
g j'ai d'autres chiens qui vivent à la
campagne parce qu'ils sont qui sont plus
gros chez le chien de mon frère qui
s'appelle watson qui a son caractère
alors ils ont tous des surnoms à watson
ces lavages blanchette
c'est un chien de chasse mais il a je
m'étais la chasse et puis les très
peureux guerre et alors il a ses petites
manières c'est lui le plus de pays sont
encore de tous les trois chiens puis
ajustable le petit noir qui est un
bâtard qu'on a eu tout petit en disant
c'est le le chien de johnny et à tous
les deux avec watson ce sont des
campagnes a alors on est obligé de faire
un système de sas quand on arrive à la
campagne parce qu'entre le chat le chien
qui habite à paris et deux autres qui
habite à la campagne qui sont assez
solitaire il ya des jalousies qui secret
je lève toute la famille est très
habitué à fermer les portes fermées les
portes watson et là vous avez fermé les
faire entrer snif oui alors tous être
organisé dans cette maison
les chiens ce côté tellement innocent
est tellement dépendants de leurs
maîtres et
et c'est ce qui est plus touchantes
comme les petits-enfants c'est comme
tout ce qui est comme ça vulnérables est
tout à fait dépendant de vous c'est très
touchant nous dit on se sent tout à fait
responsable de com
ils sont tellement gentils
ok
m
jeter